so we already know that adult film
actress stormy Daniels was paid a
hundred and thirty thousand bucks in
hush money she also signed a
nondisclosure agreement for an alleged
affair with Donald Trump that took place
as far as we knew before Trump was
President of the United States right
when Trump was a private citizen and
that's something that his defenders have
been focusing on this is stuff that
Trump allegedly did while he was a
private citizen but now we're hearing
more from stormy Daniels lawyer Michael
avenatti who appeared in a number of CNN
interviews recently one with Jake Tapper
and he's now alleging a lot of different
stuff none all of which individually
would be totally blocked buster
the first allegation being that some of
these incidents between stormy Daniels
and President Donald Trump took place
while Donald Trump was president which
now is painting a drastically different
scenario in situation here's clip number
one obviously a big debate about how
relevant an extramarital affair when
Donald Trump was a private citizen and
alleged extramarital affair is to the
job he's doing right now is there
anything in the litany of accusations
you would call them facts that surround
this case that happened while Donald
Trump was president yes can you go any
further than that no and to those who
say hey this is just an alleged affair
back when Donald Trump was a private
citizen who cares you would say it's all
about the cover-up alright Michael
avenatti thank you so much for your time
appreciate the other picked big piece of
news from stormy Daniels attorney is
that she was physically threatened to
not talk about what she knew that's what
Michael avenatti said to CNN's Chris
Cuomo let's look at that clip what are
you alleging was done to your client in
terms of pressure to stay quiet
well I'm not alleging anything I'm
stating a fact and the fact is that my
client was physically threatened to stay
silent about what she knew about Donald
Trump the details surrounding that she's
going to discuss I'm sure on the 60
Minutes interview on March 25 and the
American people are going to weigh
her veracity and the third piece of
alleged news is that there are six more
women with similar stories about Donald
Trump
although avenatti says he's not yet
vetted those stories in total this one's
with Anderson Cooper do you find the
stories of these other women who you say
have come to you are credible or are
there any similarities in terms of
circumstances
good evening Anderson as of tonight
we've been approached by six separate
women with similar stories to my client
I want to stress that we have not vetted
these stories to any great degree
however the initial consultations the
initial information that we're receiving
indicates that there are some striking
similarities between their stories and
that of my client miss Clifford can you
say if any of these women have
non-disclosure agreements yes they do at
least two of them can you say can you
say is it from the same LLC that Michael
Cohen set up before for the one with
stormy Daniels we don't know yet Wow
there's lots of little facts that start
to make more sense when you hear this
stuff like for example months ago I
reported to you the White House is no
longer releasing visitor logs all right
we figured probably has to do with
lobbyists hiding the fact that the
swamps not really being drained maybe it
did maybe it had to do with this that
there were people visiting Trump at the
White House that they didn't want to be
publicly known it's almost impossible at
this point to keep track of all the
little details but what I think is clear
is that listen stormy Daniels played a
very small role in this administration
yes she was at the White House yes she
was involved in debriefing the president
but it's not the same type of debriefing
that Stephen Bannen was doing when we
said he would debrief the presidents I
get the sense that attorney Michael
avenatti is doing a really good job here
of letting Trump and his attorney
Michael Cohen dig their own graves but
who does this avenatti guy think he is
he probably went to some loser fake news
school where they teach all sorts of oh
wait a vinod he went
university of pennsylvania say mistrial
well listen he didn't go to Wharton
that's the one department at UPenn where
the actual smart people go this really
puts the rush of stuff in context for me
right Trump is tois us to believe that
there's just no way Trump could be
manipulated by a foreign power that
specializes in this stuff yet a pornstar
has him over a barrel and it's
unrealistic that Putin would we are
going to be following this not because I
really care that much about what stormy
Daniels did or didn't do it's that we
care about as Michael avenatti said the
legality of the cover-up